like i don't know
like giving more like a proper end of the pose
like beautifully before i move on to the next one i guess
complete this of my narration
oh about what i was thinking
i didn't really think anything i was just
thinking of the next pose i'm doing i guess so there's not much things to think
so i didn't narrate it i was just narrating what i feel i could be i could do better
so yeah i guess i just
didn't think anything much so i don't know very much but that's all like i was thinking about
your way your performance according to the how for sure i'll say just squash it okay
as you can see your pattern is scored uh based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your one is your one
as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy
and our presentation on the site so we'll start off with the accuracy first
so uh your accuracy is actually scored from
a four so from the number four uh you're actually marked during your presentation of your
pattern and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake yeah minus
0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 1 you get 3, if you have a major mistake you get minus 1 and if that's leadless attended 기준은 0.1
if it's a major mistake get minus of 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.1 and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake it minus a zero point 1. If it's a minor of a 0.C, you get minus 0.1075 if it's a TYOs
major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two
so with a minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a out of block if it's
not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a
minor mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block
in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a reach hand strike instead so that would be a
major mistake so with the minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example there's about 20 steps
it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps
so the reason for that would mean it needs to be absolutely perfect to get
to not get a deduction of 0.1
so it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes
so what would that be so we'll leave that there uh on this side and we'll come back and we'll
just calculate the square at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left
but you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try to avoid
any of these major mistakes so uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to
the presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six uh this
six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here
so with this one uh for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm
is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out of two as well so
we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one whether it's your blocks your kicks your
kicks anything you are that you do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well
so that it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be
both strong and fast to get uh high in that in that category the next part is your rhythm
so the rhythm uh when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just
really fast all the way through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind
of effect to it as well so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of
two uh the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically
uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so i say you're
doing your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but
you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell oh you're not
really uh confident i'm not really confident i'm not really confident i'm not really confident
you're a little bit nervous so that's why we need to kind of improve on on as well so i'm just
coming out to this side so with this one four color belts and black belts it's actually scored
a little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where
where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so
say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to everyone
else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than average in the
judges eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a one or even a 0.9
if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or 1.4 so each individual uh category you need to
obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt generally depending on the competition you
will be scored from a 1.1 to a 1.3 to a 1.4 so that's your average and then your score for the
judges eyes you might get scored a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average uh that you start from so
say your current speed uh was above average uh average you might get scored a one point say
let's say 1.4 for now uh say your rhythm was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be just
a 1.3 but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3
so that's your average your average was 1.4 so i'm gonna start from average here so you can get
as high as you can so you can do your best and then you're still gonna get a 1.3 so you get a
one point zero so that's your average so let's say a one point zero so with this one we'll come
over uh down to this side so with this one uh as i was saying it's a total of uh 10 so let's see
so for presentation we had 0.7
one two three so yeah three point seven let's say you made fifteen mistakes so with this one
get pretty high in your mistakes. This is with the judges we have three judges
usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective so from
their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made
not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges and we
average it out as well. Okay so say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes
so if they're all minus 0.1 it would be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so
this would be your accuracy score. So with our presentation like before we're
saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add these numbers after the
judges are finished scoring so you would get for this pattern a six point
two which is actually very good so I'll just talk about a little bit more now
about this number here so if you're a color belt and if you're a yellow or above
and you do your patterns it's not uncommon generally for a color belt the
average is about a four to five so if you get a number between four and five out
of ten for your pattern that's actually generally
pretty good so anything above that you can consider yourself pretty good if
you're a black book the average would say because we're talking here about the
higher presentation as an average anything from 5 to 6 is actually
considered pretty pretty good and anything over a 7 is actually considered
almost world-class so if you get a 7 for any of your patterns you generally
need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so we just went through
our poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0
accuracy is judged during your pattern presentation is after and then we get
two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously
say I was I was judge number one I would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on
the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did maybe this one
would be a little bit lower it might be a 5 point something another judge on the
other side they scored a little bit higher so we get three numbers and then
we average that as well so I hope this helped you guys so make sure you enjoy
your poomsae competitions and any time I make sure obviously you
you record down your numbers as well so it's very important to keep track of
your numbers and see if you're improving
continue
okay
pick
so this is minor errors real-time while you're watching your performance
so I can watch again and then do this right
yeah you're gonna be doing this while you're watching so we cannot pause scripting
the video okay this is for major errors and then power and speed coordination rhythm and expression
of energy okay incorrect stance minor timings light hand forward position small violent vocal
i do a lot of movement and correct music yeah so you can balance a lot of positive mind three
seconds okay
okay
so
I'm not sure how I did it, I definitely need to get more, so this, and this, and this.